it's time for the left to fold up their
fantasy tents if they hate Donald Trump
so much maybe they should focus on
winning the 2020 presidential election
instead of this Russia collusion
delusion nonsense that's been wasting
our time our money and dividing our
nation for the past two years the
nonstop personal vendetta against the
president by Muller and his rabid team
of trump aiding prosecutors breathlessly
reported by the Trump hating media at
every turn is so intense that they
proudly beat their leftist chests every
time they issue an indictment against
someone anyone most of whom are living
in Russia and will never be brought to
justice here or anywhere else for that
matter or have been indicted for events
that preceded Trump or for lying to the
FBI which we later find out wasn't even
considered alive by the FBI agents or is
so serious that one guy got a whopping
14 days in jail bottom line none of the
indictments the special counsel has
brought has tied the president to Russia
but you wouldn't know it from these guys
a lot of paper here tonight but the one
thing that jumped out at me is the
president states individual one directed
a crime so right now we have a sitting
president States who committed two
felonies while running for president and
so if history means anything in the
Trump era if precedent means anything in
the Trump era Donald Trump will be must
be impeached because of the crimes
prosecutors say he committed in the
michael cohen case robert muller is
essentially then saying here congress
here's an impeachable defense offense
you decide I think what this totality of
today's filings show that the the house
is going to have little choice the way
this is going other than to start
impeachment proceedings so did the
president director felony if Michael
Cohen who is probably one of the most
flawed prosecution witnesses I've ever
Sene and that's saying something is
relied upon to prove beyond a reasonable
doubt that Donald Trump circumvented
campaign finance laws they might just as
well be whistling Dixie
up the Mississippi permit me number one
if the president directed any payment
why what was the state of mind what was
he thinking what wasn't he thinking do
you really think Michael Cohen knows
maybe he didn't want his wife to find
out maybe he didn't want his family to
find out maybe he was trying to prevent
any tarnish on his brand or maybe to
simply get the woman off his back it
wouldn't be the first time a high
profile person paying to get rid of a
nuisance lawsuit now there is a
presumption of innocence in every
criminal case in every criminal
investigation and never a presumption
against that without evidence that acts
are done for purely criminal reasons and
don't forget it was citizen Donald
Trump's money that was used and not
campaign money for whatever might have
occurred before he was president unlike
another president beached for acts that
occurred with a young intern in the Oval
Office while he was president and so far
30 million taxpayer dollars for this
nonsense it's nonsense
especially because Barack Obama was in a
position to actually do something about
so-called Russian interference
but did nothing except to tell Putin to
knock it off and even that I don't
believe and as for the testimony of
holier-than-thou Cardinal James Comey
the grandstanding political operative
who believes the rules don't apply to
him and who fought so hard to testify in
an open setting I'm left with only one
thought Jim why the hell did you want
your testimony but
house in judiciary and oversight
committees to be in public
Jim you readily admitted almost 250
times that you didn't recall or didn't
remember honestly it would have been and
is less embarrassing for you to do it
behind closed doors but slippery jim
says he doesn't remember important facts
about the most important FISA case in
American history that required his
approval he states it doesn't matter
where the fake dossier came from yet he
still has total confidence in the FISA
process that he corrupted now I don't
have to go over this again commis been
found by the inspector general to have
mishandled the Clinton email
investigation to have lied before
Congress not about exonerating Hillary
before the investigation was done and to
be an admittedly cur of sensitive
information that he wanted to get to the
New York Times who his friend and when
asked if he would have fired the lovers
on this staff Peter struck and Lisa
Paige who openly communicated their
hatred and disdain for candidate Donald
Trump yet all the while investigating
him Comey states he can't answer in the
abstract doesn't deny he would have
allowed them to stay on the Clinton
investigation in spite of their hate as
long as they gave an explanation no
surprise Jim since you're a pal of the
Clintons the most shocking is commis
role in the theater of the absurd of
fake dossier paid for by a woman who's
his friend running for president and
he's best friends with a special counsel
in charge of the case and he doesn't
remember key details like the party who
funded it in the most blatant display of
public corruption and personal political
cover in American history shame on you
Jim
and that's my open